المشاهدين اهلا وسهلا بكم الى هذه التغطيه
التي ينضم الينا فيها زميل محمد ابو عبيد
اهلا في قناه الحدث ارحب بك محمد في
تغديتنا للعربيه في عيدها في العشرين لم
يكن الثاني من يناير 2020 يوما سهلا على
كل العاملين في قناتي العربيه والحدث حيث
استيقظنا على فاجعه فقد سيده الحوار
السياسي في العالم العربي الزميل العزيزه
نجوى قاسم لحظات توقفت وساعات تباطات
وايام بدات شاحبه في ملامح محبي نجوى من
المحيطي الى الخليج لكن الحزن الكبير
يومها لم يمنعنا من النواصل مسيرتها
الطويله في العربيه والحدث بتكريمها حتى
اخر لحظاتها على هذه الارض ولنجوى نقول
انت باقيه سينا مثل زهر البيلسان
مشاهدينا الكرام نتوقف مع هذا الخبر بقلوب
مؤمنه بقضاء الله وقدره تنعى شبكه العربيه
والعربيه الحدث الزميله الاعلاميه نجوى
قاسم
بان شبكتنا الاعلاميه نقصت ركنا من
اركانها حدث اليوم مع نجوى قاسم
اهلا بكم الى حدث يوم جديد
رحيل صاحبته نجوى قاسم الوجه الذي اطل على
الشاشه قرابه الثلاثين عاما
ترى في ملامحه جديه الاعلاميه القديره
[موسيقى]
اختبئوا وراءه قلب الانسان الذي عرفه كل
من التقاها
لبنان اكيد
كونوا معي انا نجوى قاسم في تغطيه عبر
شاشات الحدث من هنا من تونس تغطيه مزيانه
برشا
مع نجوى قاسم
[موسيقى]
شارع العالم العربي شباب العالم العربي
اليوم يريدون ان يتعاطوا سياسه اكثر
يريدون ان يعرفوا دولهم اكثر ان يكون لهم
دور اكثر وهذا يجبرنا على اللحاق بهم
[موسيقى]
مع استمرار معاناتها مع الكاميرات واصوات
الضيوف في اذنها نجوى قاسم تضيف التكييف
الى قائمه المضايقات وتناشد مسؤوليه
الصيانه بالتدخل لوقف تدهور الاوضاعلك
[موسيقى]
لا كيف اصبحنا الحدث
ببساطه كنا هناك
لاول مره بتوع على فكره انه ايه في شخص
هلا انت كنت عم تتحدث معه وبعد لحظه مات
[موسيقى]
لحظات تاريخيه نتذكر فيها زميله وايضا
المرحومه نجوى والمرحوم سعد السيلاوي
يستحقان ان يكون هذا البث المشترك على
الاقل من اجل هذا التذكار والذاكره بكل
الاحوال معي في الاستوديو موجود معنا
الزميل بول حداد رئيس التحرير في قناه
الحدث فوق اهلا فيك معنا في هذه التغطيه
الخاصه المخصصه للمرحومه نجوى الزميل
الرائعه والمرحوم سعد السيلاوي ايضا انت
ممن يعني عاشر ويعني شارك المسيره
الاعلاميه للراحله نجوى ماذا يعني ياتي في
ذهنك عندما نتذكر المرحومه منذ بداياتها
في مسيرتها الاعلاميه
اول شيء مساء الخير لك محمد وكمان لمحمد
الحقيقه اول شيء اذا بدي احكي عن نجوى
لازم اضحك لانه ما لازم نحول هاي المناسبه
لمناسبه حزن انه هي كل الصور اللي بتظهر
فيها وكل حياتها كانت فيها مره حيه وساعد
كمان يعني ما فينا ننكر سعد من اكثر الناس
المرحين بالحياه على كل انا اللي بحب
اقوله اول شيء انه
نجوى هي قبل ما تكون مذيعه هي صحفيه وكتير
فرق كبير بين المذيع فقط والمذيع والصحفي
بعتقد انتم اثنينكم
تعرفوا اكثر من غيركم لانه انتم كمان
صحفيين وبتعرفوا شو الفرق بين الاثنين
يعني
نجوى مش بس تيجي تقدم نشط اخبار نجوى كانت
الساعه ثلاثه الصبح اذا في خبر اجاب تبعته
بالتلفين بتلاحق ضيوفها بتقرا كل الملفات
متابعه جدا جدا يعني ما كانت اختي الصحافه
كمهنه او كوظيفه لانه الصحافه اذا بياخذها
واحد مهني او وظيفه ما بيمشي حاله يعني ما
كان عندها اجازه ما عندها ليل ما عندها
نهار كل الوقت كان عايشه يعني عايشه لهذه
المهنه اذا بدكم
بتبادر لكم كمان لازاني انه الصحفي ما فيك
انت تعمله هو بيخلق مثل الفنان انت فيك
تدربه على التقنيات فيك تدربوا توجهوا
ببعض المسائل بس انا برايي انه الصحفي
بيخلق هيك بيخلق هو صحفي هذا عم نحكي عن
يعني اذا بدك نحكي عن نجوى كصحفيه وكمذيعه
وكمهنيه هلا في اشياء تانيه
حياتك خارج اطار المهنه يمكن بعدين نرجع
نحكي فيها اذا بدكم طيب وهذا قدره لسؤال
التالي خارج الشاشه كيف كانت المرحومه
نجوى قاسم
شوفوا انا ما بدي احكيك للشيات على موضوع
قديش كانت بتساعد وقديش هذا موضوع بينها
وبين الله بس انا بعرف تفاصيل كثيره قديش
هي
بتساعد بالحياه انا بدي احكي عن اشياء
تاني بالحياه شوي حلوه فيها اول شيء نجوى
صوتها حلو بتغني
كنا نقعد بجلسات كانت تغني كانت بعتقد
بعتقد انه زميلنا يلي هلا موجود بالجاليري
ماجد ابراهيم بيعرف
قديش نجوى صوتها حلو قديش مره كنا بصهره
وبعتقد كان عم يعزف على العود ويمكن هو
ناسيها هيدا الواقعه وغنت بعدين بذكر حتى
الغنيه هلا هي لفيروز امي نامت على بكير
ما بعرف اذا عم يسمعني وفي جواب عم يسمع
وشايفك شو رايك يا ماجد
يلا هلا ماجد بده يعطيك الجواب يا بول
اهلا بك ودائما
واهلك محمد ومحمد البث المشترك الله يرحم
نجوى صديقه عظيمه وزي ما قال بول يعني في
شغلات كثير احنا نعرفها كاصدقاء عنها غير
العالم تعرفها كصحفيه ومذيعه عظيمه
مهما راحت باقيه في قلوبنا باقيه فينا في
كل مناسباتنا السعيده
قصه الاستماع والفن هذا جزء من شخصيه نجوى
الفنيه الجميله كانت دايمتش معنا اغاني
فيروز
نتناقش فيها
تحديدا ونجوى ما اعرف شو اقول لانه باقي
فينا نجوى بكل مناسباتنا الحلوه قبل ما
نحزن عليها الله يرحمها الله يرحمها شكرا
شكرا ماجد فول
كان معروفا يعني الرحله الزميله نجوى انه
كانت محبه ايضا للعمل الميداني يعني لم
تكن من الناس الذين يعشقون فقط الجلوس على
طاوله التقليد كانت تقترح
وتطلب وتغامر بنفس الوقت صحيح طبعا هلا
انتم بتعرفوا يمكن حتى خلال النهار انحكى
وقت اللي راحت غطت بالعراق ومن صابت
بانفجار المكتب وميت عنا زملاء كمان غطينا
انا واياها حرب تموز لمده شهر بلبنان مع
كل ما جرى فيها حتى كنا نشتغل بظروف كتير
صعبه بتعرفوا ما في كهرباء ما في كل يعني
اذا بدكم الارضيه الصالحه لتعمل تغطيه
محترمه حتى كنا نشتغل
عالاوراق وبالاشارات وبالو وما نقدر نحكي
مع بعض حتى احيانا طبعا برجع بقول لك
الصحفي ما بكون بس بيقعد على الكرسي
وبيقرا اخبار صحافه بجيب خبر الصحافه
بيجيب معلومه صحفي بينزل على الارض صحفي
بغطي الصحافه بياكل خبيط بياكل قتل صح
وانتم برجع بقول لكم يعني اكيد بتعرفوا
هذا الشيء ومرقتو فيه اكيد
كمان بحب ضيف شغله هلا كمان عليك شوي لازم
تطلع الناس من الجو انه
كمان نجوى ما كانت سهله على فكره صاحب
الكن هذا الشيء يعني بشغل انا عم بحكي
كانت صعبه انا بحكي عن نفسي انا كنت مرق
بعد القصص هيك يعني احيانا انه خلص وما
تاخديها هالقد وما بعرف شو ما بعرف شو كنا
نعلق مع بعض ونبقى بالاسابيع ما نحكي انا
بذكر وقتها مره يعني
[موسيقى]
بكون معها انا على الهواء بدنا نحكي مع
بعض ما احكي احكي مع المخرج قل له الا كذا
المخرج بقول لي بتقول لك كذا طبعا هذا
الشيء ترد عليك من خلال المخرج ونخرج
احيانا نرجع نتصالح ونرجع طبعا هلا بصير
بالشغل بس انه بعد شغله بدي اضيفها كمان
هيدي رح تنصفكم لالكم كمان
الناس بتفكر انه المذيعين هني حيطان او
باب خشب ما بحسوا وما بيتفاعلوا ما
بيعرفوا الناس انه المذيعين مطلوب منهم
انه ما يعملوا ولا اي رد فعل على الهواء
قدام امام اي خبر عم بيقدموه لانه الصلب
مهنتهم انه يكونوا حيادي
بس انا بعرف انه كانت تبكي بمواقف كثيره
باشياء ماساويه كثيره بتغطيات كبيره مثل
ما انتم بصير معكم انا بعرف انه انتم نفس
الشيء بس الناس دايما بتفكركم انه انتم
ناس هيك مجردين وبلا احاسيس ولا قلب هذا
الشيء مش صحيح بس بحب الكم بقول للناس
يعني انه ياما شفتها عم تبكي ياما
ما بقى فيي اتحمل هذه المشاهد او ما بقى
شوف بس على الهواء طبعا ما حدا ابدا
كانت نجوى على طبيعتها امام الشاشه نعرف
احيانا بين المذيعين قد يتصنعون احيانا من
اجل رسميه المكان ورسميه المواجهه مع
الشاشه الى اي مدى كانت نجوى طبيعيه
بطبيعتها
هيك خطر لي سؤال كونك رئيس تحرير في قناه
الحدث ومسؤول بالمحصله بالرغم من يعني هذا
الاعلاميه اللي كانت تمثلها يعني والقدره
الاعلاميه الزميله الراحله نجوى هل كان في
تعامل يختلف بين زميل وزميل بسبب القدره
المهنيه امكان الكل امامك بالتعامل الكل
لا لا خليني اقول لك شغله كمان ما راح
اقعد هلا اعمل
واحكي عنا بطولات لنجوى واعمل انه لا بس
انا هذا صار مسال لالي اذا بدك اساله لكل
الزملاء وهن بجاوبوا بكتفي بس جاوبك بهيك
وهني راح يعطوك الجواب لانه نجوى انسانه
متلا متل اي شخص عاديه جدا بتحب كل العالم
بتتعامل مع كل العالم بكل بساطه بس بفضل
تسالون راح اعطيكم الجواب وانا اشهد على
ذلك بول بكل الاحوال بالتاكيد غياب نجوى
بشكل كبير على الاحتلالات الحدث وعلى قناه
العربيه مع الاحترام والتقدير لكافه
النجوم والمبدعين في القناتين ولكن مكان
نجوى في الاعلام العربي مفقود دائما
رحم الله نجوى قاسم رحمه الله شكرا لوجودك
معنا الزميل حداد رئيس التحرير في قناه
الحدث شكرا شكرا